[Music]
welcome back to curious archive this
video is the third part of a series
exploring the incredible speculative
evolution project of serena the world of
birds serena was created by dylan beta a
terrific artist and world
i have links below where you can follow
and support his work when we left off
serena was home to a single super
continent at the end of the pangea scene
now it is the ultima scene the final era
of serena and one more incredible than
any that came before at 250 million
years post-establishment the
supercontinent has split into northern
and southern landmasses this period will
see the rise of multiple forms of highly
intelligent life and in much the same
way that elephants dolphins crows and
humans which as far as we know are some
of the most intelligent animals ever to
exist all happen to live in an
overlapping time period a similar
convergence will occur on serenade
during the ultima scene on the enormous
grassland of the southern continent many
key species can be found like the
successful cirquagdons who look almost
unrecognizable from their roots as tiny
fish 250 million years prior giant
archangels flock nearby a type of
metamorph bird a curious classification
that will define the early ultimacine in
scavenging close by a large bumble
badger makes off with a young
cerquagodant foreshadowing a rivalry
between the two groups that will change
serena forever
but we're not there yet right now
soft-built birds the very descendants of
ancient water snuffles are prospering
during the ultima scene organisms like
the bludge birds are now extinct but
another offshoot of the mittens the
southern squid stork or squirk are still
going strong these intelligent creatures
are omnivores and use their tentacle
beaks to grab hold of hidden worms and
mollusks in temperate forests another
soft-built bird is the shy and reclusive
moo a horse-sized herbivore that lives
perpetually on alert why would a
creature of this size be so skittish the
truth is it has good reason to be
elsewhere in these forests lurk the
grappler predators similar in build to
the moo which are their preferred prey
their tentacle-like beaks are lined with
sharp teeth and tipped with talons
making them deadly apex predators a
different branch of soft bills are the
teres a group that includes the
hilariously named newts whose facial
tentacles fused over time into one
elongated fleshy mouth when threatened
these birds are able to scoop up their
eggs and carry it against their chins
where a small fold of feathered skin
keeps it secure while they flee a
related group are the neckbeards who
like the newts have an amusing name and
carry their eggs against their chins
although the neckbeards take this to a
new extreme by having a more defined
pouch to hold their eggs allowing them
to stop brooding on the ground at all in
warmer forests you can find the lumber
beasts the largest living mucks on all
of serena standing up to 25 feet or 7.6
meters tall and weighing over two tons
the group however is in the decline with
most now wandering the force in
isolation in the branches above however
life flourishes here much changed
tree-dwelling tributes swing near the
bizarre tentacled boras an offshoot of
the soft-build mittens truly fantastic
forms of life on the subject of
fantastic forms possibly no creatures
are more unique than the changelings or
metamorph birds although the metamorph
group reaches their peak in the early
ultima scene their ancestry goes all the
way back to the cryo scene the metamorph
line began with birds that laid small
shellless eggs which made the process of
reproduction faster but led to their
chicks being born extremely
underdeveloped almost looking like bird
tadpoles before they've reached
adulthood over millions of years this
larva-like stage became more viable and
more complex with the tiny young
developing stronger forelimbs to move
around more efficiently before becoming
adults other metamorph embryos were laid
in the water and became more fish-like
adapting for life in an aquatic
environment millions of years on the end
result is perhaps the most adaptable and
physically diverse vertebrate clade ever
to exist among their varied ranks are
the zebra tweezel bumblebee size birds
that begin life as worm like larva and
are among the smallest birds ever
another metamorph is the blue-throated
boom singer one of the largest birds
ever to walk the land which stands up to
50 feet or 15 and a quarter meters tall
some aquatic metamorphs like the
long-built pike bird have even abandoned
their adult forms altogether through an
extreme expression of neoteny
essentially becoming fish-like organisms
truly incredible
other metamorph birds have a somewhat
unfortunate lot in life like the day
flight bird these extreme metamorphs
begin as incredibly fish-like larvae
they then consume themselves in a silken
wrapping of their own saliva which
hardens into what is essentially a
second egg within which they
metamorphosize into adults tragically
however the adults lack mouths
altogether the day flights therefore
live only a single day in their adult
forms during which they lay eggs to
repeat the cycle and if this sounds too
outside the box to evolve know that real
world mayfly insects have a very similar
life cycle that ends in an adult form
that lacks a mouth perhaps the most
impressive metamorph bird however is the
storm sonar a highly migratory archangel
with a wingspan of 50 feet or over 15
meters the largest flying animals ever
to exist despite being larger than some
airplanes storm sonars are gentle giants
named for their eerie echoing calls
as previously stated aside from the
metamorph birds one of the major themes
of the ultimacine is the development of
intelligence among many animal lineages
in the ocean the herbivorous ring-necked
porplets and carnivorous sea strikers
are two such examples both species are
social animals with keen minds the sea
strikers have learned to operate like
sheepdogs systematically hurting the
porplets to create a consistent food
source considering how advanced and
similar both species are however it's an
unsettling system proving nature can be
quite cruel and nothing is quite as
cruel as an ending in the words of the
author as happens to everything in the
cosmos from flowers to stars serena
itself is now dying the moon is starting
to slowly cool down and it will never
warm up again as stated before the
ultima scene will be the final era in
the saga of serena but before the
curtain falls on serena's finale there
may still be time for something truly
incredible to occur over the past
several million years one branch of the
cirquagdons has begun an extraordinary
transformation for eons cerquagdons have
been unable to feed on told trees due to
their short necks but now one species
has specialized a body part that will
allow them to do so not their necks but
their ears from their hearing structure
some sergeants have developed
antler-like mobile limbs that are able
to reach up and hook branches an
adaptation which might one day have
intriguing consequences
before that day comes however other
branches of the triboteers are also
doing pretty well for themselves
rivaling the birds and diversity several
million years after crawling onto land
take the painted rippandor the widest
spread canethyr on land in the early
ultimacine whose jaws have a unique
shearing motion that helps them consume
prey or the thorngazer a hairless
moledot able to survive off bristly
desert plants alone and in the skies the
branch that became the tribats is also
still going strong like the blue eared
vibrotarix a nectar drinking specialist
that uses a long brush tip tongue to
gather food and in the seas yet another
offshoot is becoming aquatic like the
spotted snail smashers a strange-looking
group that feeds on various types of
mollusks between the metamorph birds and
various tributeers serena is at an
all-time high of biodiversity but now
the moon is truly getting cold we are
now in the middle ultimacine and a new
ice age is setting in
in this new world only the most
adaptable will survive
sextacorn thorn gazers are one such
species which have become thick coated
ice age herbivores with specialized
facial horns that give them a menacing
look despite appearances these creatures
aren't overly aggressive just interested
in self-defense from ice age predators
another curious looking new arrival in
the ice age are mammoth trunkos
descendants of the neckbeards that have
developed both a longer beak trunk and a
truly robust neck pouch to carry their
eggs in which has come in handy in the
cooling temperatures
at this point in the ice age the largest
archangels are sadly in trouble as the
rapidly cooling world is making their
migratory patterns less and less
effective some arch angels are adapting
however by becoming smaller and less
migratory offshoots called serifs
examples include the tundratisse which
might not be as spectacular as their
larger relatives but are much better
adapted for this new world closer to the
equator a story unlike any other is now
at last set to begin over the past
several million years a group of
circuits called the antlers which have
become more intelligent with more
complex antler-like manipulator
appendages find themselves blindsided by
a creature that hunts them with an
astonishing degree of planning and
foresight these carnivorous life forms
the gravediggers are descendants of the
bumble badgers while other predators
evolve sharper teeth or longer claws to
catch their prey the gravedigger has
developed a bigger brain they have
incredibly learned how to make traps by
digging deep pits into the earth with
their powerful arm claws and using their
beaks to sharpen sticks which they place
at the bottom it's a kind of trap the
antlers are helpless against
but not for long by catching the less
weary antlers the grave diggers are
inadvertently selecting for smarter and
smarter prey and so the evolutionary
arms race is set into motion it will be
perhaps the most rapid of any so far on
serena as well as the most pivotal soon
one particular type of antler the
standing antler will become intelligent
enough to avoid traps and in turn
therefore give rise to gravediggers with
more effective trapping abilities
in time the antlers and gravediggers
both achieve sapience able to use basic
tools and becoming smart enough to avoid
each other while no longer predator and
prey however a hatred has risen between
both groups that would define the coming
era in unexpected ways
the standing antlers have now become the
woodcrafters one of a kind looking
social organisms with exceptionally
advanced brains and highly expressive
faces for communication woodcrafters
have also developed a whistling language
somewhat similar to the sounds of an elk
and can craft spears to defend against
predators although they themselves are
herbivores beers aren't the only thing
they've learned how to craft however as
their name implies woodcrafters have
learned to shape the trunks and branches
of trees creating basket-like homes as
well as fences bridges over rivers and
sculptures of beasts or abstract
creatures from their lore for the
woodcrafters are developing a culture
one that is in large part defined by a
hatred of predators meanwhile the
gravediggers are achieving a similar
level of brain function while their
marks on this world are subtler than the
woodcrafters often little more than art
carved into the sides of trees at the
edge of their territory they are still
the marks of high intelligence however
the gravediggers are learning to be
careful when they make these marks as it
can attract unwanted dangers the
woodcrafters which have at this point
driven most predators from their
environment on a crusade to make a safer
world are now leaving their territory in
search of more predators to slay once
the prey of the gravediggers the
woodcrafters have turned the tables
entirely and are now killing
gravediggers not out of self-defense but
due to a misplaced crusade
eventually however an incredible
transformation occurs as they expand out
woodcrafters begin to encounter barrier
trees made by gravediggers who never
learn to stop making art out of fear of
discovery at first the woodcrafters
assume these markings are the work of
some unfamiliar woodcrafter village
after all in their limited world view
they are the only ones intelligent
enough to create art but there are no
signs of others like them in this region
only their old enemies in the words of
the author the woodcrafters had set out
to create a world without monsters and
it is only then that they realize that
they have become them
with the revelation that they are not
alone at their arbitrary pinnacle of
life that the monstrous gravediggers
they'd slain for years are intelligent
just like they are shock quickly spreads
through the woodcrafter communities and
it is at this time of great cultural
uncertainty that the trajectory of the
two species shifts forever from a small
choice an orphaned gravedigger infant
left alone after the death of their
mother one of the last gravediggers ever
hunted for sport is taken in by an
empathetic woodcrafter warrior to be
this gravedigger child aptly referred to
as bridge is at first regarded with
suspicion by the other woodcrafters soon
however they learned to socialize with
the group displaying a personality and
emotional complexity normally hidden
from all outsiders bridge would forge a
path for cooperation between the two
most intelligent species on serena the
woodcrafters and the gravediggers
intertwined since their shared beginning
would break a multi-million year cycle
of violence between intelligent predator
and intelligent prey in time other young
gravediggers following bridge's example
would abandon their territorial ways and
imprint on woodcrafters and in turn the
woodcrafters would accept the young
gravediggers into their society
eventually the younger generations would
never know a world where antlers and
gravediggers were enemies and whatever
the future would hold the two species
would face it together perhaps only
tragedy awaits all life on serena as it
continues to cool past the point of no
return but it's always been a saga of
both the good and the bad a story of
life and death of extinction and
evolution in any case for the time being
one thing is for sure the mud wickets
and bumblets sure came a long way
dylan betta has released some content
set after this period but i don't want
to dive further into the future until
the whole project has been unveiled so
it's a story which we'll have to be told
another time for now this is the end of
our three-part series if you found this
speculative evolution epic as
enthralling as i did please follow and
support dylan beta and his project using
the links below there's also plenty that
i wasn't able to cover in this limited
time frame so if you're curious about
learning more of serena links to his
site are also in the description and as
always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support and like subscribe and hit the
notification icon to stay up to date on
all things curious see you in the next
video
you